[MUSIC PLAYING]
MOR GILAD: Today,
we're going to talk
about how you can
build professional web
applications really quickly
with Corvid using Google Cloud
Services.
My name is Mor.
I'm a developer at Wix, and
I've been working at Corvid
in the past three years.
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
So hey, everyone.
My name is Giedrius.
For the last two years,
I've been working
on Corvid's database systems.
So let's talk today about what
you need to build a modern web
application.
MOR GILAD: Well,
first, we know that we
want it to be super-fast,
because no one likes waiting.
Second, we want to be able
to store huge amounts of data
and analytics capabilities.
And third, we want to have
professional UI in order
to get our users engaged
with our service.
So I'm bringing to
you Corvid by Wix.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
So what is Corvid?
Well, it's many things.
First, it's a visual platform
to design your web applications.
This is what Wix is famous for.
Its our
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
editor for building web pages.
So it's no HTML and no CSS
in building the front end.
MOR GILAD: And it's also a
truly serverless platform,
which means you can build
your back end services,
and call it from front end
as if it was a simple method.
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
And there is no setup.
There is no setting up virtual
machines, security, databases.
Everything is there for you
once you start your project.
And furthermore, you can
deploy your application
with a single click of a button.
And in a few seconds, it's
deploying into Wix servers
all around the world.
MOR GILAD: So now, we're
going to show you a short demo
that we created that is an
actual blog application on San
Francisco food scene.
What you can see over here,
when Giedrius will scroll down,
you can see posts on
restaurants from San Francisco.
Each post contain the name of
the restaurant, a description,
and an image.
Now when we'll go up, we'll
see that we have tags.
And we can filter our
posts by the tags.
Now, the fun part
about our application
is that the tags are being
automatically created
when we added the post.
So yesterday, Giedrius and
I went to this really cool
restaurant together with
our Corvid team over here
that's called Cow Marlowe.
And Giedrius will write a short
description on our restaurant,
and we'll add a photo
that we took yesterday.
Now, when we click on Upload
Post, what's happening is,
first, we upload the image
to Wix media servers.
Then we save the post in our own
integrated database collection.
After that, we're
doing two things.
We're calling Google
NOP on the text
that we wrote to receive
entities on the text.
After that, we're calling
Google Vision API on the image
to get labels on our image.
When we finished with that,
we combine the two results
and create tags from that.
Then we'll save it in our own
integrated database again.
Let's go to our new post
and see how it looks like.
This is the new restaurant.
And, if we'll go down, we'll
see that we have some new tags
automatically created for us.
And then we also have
the friendship tag
because we are friends.
Now, we'll go to the
editor, and we'll
see how it's actually done.
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
So here, you
can see our Add New Place form.
It has regular form.
It has few input components
for restaurant name,
short description, image,
and a nice red button
for uploading the post.
All of these components
are connected
to the posted data sets
you can see over there.
What it allows us
to do is it allows
us to submit the data from the
form directly to our database
without writing a
single line of code.
Now, since we want to
do more processing,
we want to call
Google, so we are
adding some code that's going
to run after the [INAUDIBLE]..
So here, you can see,
we're taking that same data
set that I just talked about.
And we're adding an
on-after save callback.
Now once the data is
saved to the database,
the callback is
going to be involved
and going to do a few things.
Now one of the interesting
things I want to show you
is how we called
the back end code.
You can see, we're calling
get-text-entities method.
That get-text-entities
function is actually
important from the
back end language GSW.
Now, you may think, wait, if
this is front end code, why
we are importing back end code?
So once you import back
end code from the front end
code in Corvid, what it does,
it imports special function
that, instead of calling
and calling the JavaScript
directly, will go and call the
back end service over HTTP.
So anything that's in the back
end folder and has extension
.jsw, which stands like
JavaScript read method,
any function exported from there
will become callable as a web
service.
MOR GILAD: Now
because we're using
the old js in the
back end, we want
to be able to
import NPM packages.
So, as you can see here, we're
importing Google Language API
and also Lodash.
Now when Geidrius and I
wrote this application,
we had some bugs, and we wanted
the debug our application.
So we actually added
some logging here.
But as you know,
it's a back-end file,
so we cannot see that the
logging in our console.
So what we actually used
is a new feature we have
that enables us to connect
to Google Stackdriver
and monitor our application.
So we'll go to
Google Stackdriver,
and we'll load the new logs.
And we actually can
see here the entities
that we received from Google.
Now, we'll go back.
And remember, we talked
about integrated databases
and collections.
So this is our post
collection that we used.
Each post record contains
the title, the description,
the image, and the tags
that we have on it.
Now, if we'll go to
the tags collection,
we'll see all the tags.
And we also see the posts
that's connected to the tags.
We used a multi-reference
field here.
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
Yeah, we have joins.
So what did we do?
Again, we used serverless
concurrent platform, the Visual
Builder, integrated
globally-available Corvid
database together with
globally-available Wix media
platform and combined that
with Google machine learning
services, such as NLP
and Cloud Vision API,
and used Google's
monitoring tools
to build this nice application.
And how long did we take?
MOR GILAD: We worked on that
for less than three hours
with the design and everything.
It's very easy, because we don't
need to bootstrap anything.
And it's serverless,
so we don't need
to worry about security,
hosting, nothing.
You just go into Wix,
create a new website,
enable Corvid, and start coding.
Corvid is now under
a technical preview,
so you can start using it.
All you need to do is--
I'll take my clicker--
to go to Wix website,
www.wix.com/corvid,
and start using
our great product.
GIEDRIUS GRAZEVICIUS:
So thank you
all for coming here and letting
us share a tiny fraction
of our platform's capabilities.
If you want to know
more, we invite
you to join our booth
right on that corner, where
we're going to show
demos, and we'll
let you play with the product.
Thank you.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]